E aí
[Aplausos]
e quando eu era criança eu planejava
minha vida até os 21 anos
meu passatempo preferido era esperar o
meu pai dormir para poder pegar o
documento dele e ficar sintonizando de
estação em estação enquanto a minha
imaginação voava longe
longe já tá meus 21 anos
e não senso comum de uma família negra
tradicional da Periferia a meta até os
21 É
não ser vítima de um genocídio
financiar um apartamento terminar os
estudos casa cedo
mas eu me visualizava mesmo com 21 só
para me sentir uma pessoa adulta
independente
que pode sair para dançar em algum bom
Clube enquanto toca as músicas daquele
homem ou pegar um carro numa manhã de
sol sem rumo sentindo o vento bater no
rosto enquanto toca as músicas daquele
Walkman as frequências da Rádio mexiam
comigo de uma tal forma
o que na realidade eu percebi que a
música tinha capacidade de traduzir os
meus sentimentos nem mesmo quando eu
comprei um dia
Oi e aí quando a minha mãe e o meu pai
me contaram que eu fui praticamente
Concebida de uma pista de dança eu
entendi que isso fazia parte do meu DNA
e toda vez que a gente arrastava o sofá
na sala de casa para poder dançar eu me
sentia No ritual essa criação me trouxe
um hábito voluntário ouvir música para
poder sonhar
o e através do Resgate de memórias
mas a conciliação entre o lúdico EA
realidade tipo Ok eu entendo a
transformação que essa arte pode causar
mas como expandir e praticar
o mesmo sem respostas imediatas a música
foi se tornando a minha principal
ferramenta de manutenção de poder
é de poder amar de poder sonhar de poder
curar de poder idealizar de poder ter o
passado o presente e o futuro tudo junto
e deter o poder para poder
e essa linguagem que a arte propõe quase
que espiritual onde ela não só nos
complementa como no suplementa
e me fez adotar música Como uma reza uma
reza uma oração é bom mantra
onde eu manifestava para as pessoas
materializações e Conexões
o e através desses trabalhos eu
pude enfim conhecer o mundo mágico da
Rádio
eu pude adentrar bastidores de grandes
espetáculos
e eu pude conhecer o Brasil que não
aparece na televisão e desejei muito por
preservar as origens dele
eu pude sobrevoar oceanos e não era mais
na minha imaginação
eu pude conhecer o espaço da criação
produzindo tocando gerenciando
coordenando e aprendendo e quando eu me
vi brincando nesse jardim
eu entendi que eu poderia contribuir não
só fazendo as ideias recuarem pelo meu
cérebro com as planilhas mas pelas
minhas mãos com os discos de vinil
e pela minha garganta com o microfone e
dessa ferramenta completamente ancestral
e tecnológica eu pude fazer a minha
universidade
e então eu passei a entender a tradição
do Samba o fundamento do Jazz a
resistência do funk a origem do jongo
e a elegância do Funk Sou o matriarcado
do Maracatu
e a Negritude do rock and roll
EA potência do hip-hop
e além do Passinho de baile que é uma
revolução Vital passei a me conectar com
outros povos que também estavam
dispostos a salvar o mundo
através das experiências emocionais que
a música causa eu passei pela montanha
mais linda da Jamaica onde não era
apenas a paz e o amor que eram pregados
através da música Regue mas sim a forte
Oposição a um sistema opressor injusto
manifestado da maneira mais melódica
possível isso para mim foi encontrar o
pote de ouro no fim do arco-íris em
Quantas caixas do sound system ecoavam e
com tudo isso eu descobri que a força
se ela não vende vencer são as nossas
lutas que desenvolvem as nossas forças
e quando a gente decide não se render
aí é que tá a força
Oi e a música é essa força
se você tem noção de quantas batalhas
você pode vencer de quantas lições você
pode aprender
o e de quantas pandemias não oficiais
Você pode passar apenas Ouvindo uma
música
e nós precisamos criar mais intimidade
com as frequências vibracionais
para despertar o nosso poder
é porque a gente pode muito obrigado